you can do this straight to cam this
camera here yeah beautiful there has
been a murder
and the only way to solve him is to hand
out some stirling
to the after party cast jazz
[Music]
um
uh i'm gonna go ahead and say john early
because he likes drama ike baron holtz
he's an attention [ __ ] he wants to know
who loves him who doesn't he wants to
tell people who can come to their
funeral and who cannot isaac baron holds
no questions asked would be ben because
he loves that limelight even in death
it happens to fit the episode but i'm
going to say my man schwartz got a good
voice he was practicing all day every
day trying to be a good actor but really
just wanted uh compliments on his
beautiful voice be zoe because honestly
she was in a acapella group in college
and she's actually got a beautiful
singing voice when ben sings something
very um boy band vibes this is always
singing
[Music]
that's that's that's it
[Music]
yeah it's probably me if i'm thinking of
like who's a clown like i want to say
ike uh i could say ike but also tiffany
she was so funny you know those uh memes
where ronald mcdonald putting on his
makeup like why did i do this that's him
all the time i'm gonna say ike tiffany
kelvin tiebreaker uh that's not a
tiebreaker but it's a tie a three-way
tie
[Music]
uh i'd say it's jamie dimitro because i
think i don't think he's actually
english i think it's a long con at the
baptist he's gonna be like psych guys
it's me i'm american or german something
like that
uh i am gonna go ahead and say tiffany
tiffany haddish
[Music]
ah that's always zoe ciao zoe loves to
put together an outfit showed up with
some cuties and she's really good some
freaking cuties or alana alana and zoey
i'm going to give them both best dress
because they they can wear an outfit
that's very easy that's sam richardson
very good dressed thank you you know i
can't say myself for all the good ones
someone did see you for that kind of
ride shocking i was wearing leggings all
day ever just pregnancy leggings all day
that's shocking
this show has proven that he already is
one it's so
weird he's i think actually like
becoming one now like watching those
music videos of like the xavier music
videos if this was on like the billboard
hot 100 i'd be like yeah it makes sense
he cracks me up he's holding the tension
so well between it being a joke and it
being real he's like legitimately a pop
star so for sure franco
i would say myself
i'll go ahead and say
uh uh
say me i'm gonna say ike as well he
handles a bomb like well in that he
handles it by saying you guys are too
stupid to get this
in a former like me and that former life
is current a lot of people would not
think this but alana glazer i could hold
her legs and see her with a little beer
funnel in her mouth she was in a lot of
fraternities the jennifers tia serkar
and aiden mayrie would do a double keg
stand no doubt they are down
[Music]
if i had to give myself a superlative
wow i'm kind of the king of superlatives
oh
most annoying
i would say most likely to be with child
on the after party that's my superlative
it would be most likely to give
superlatives that are top-notch
thanks for having me drew until next
time thanks for having me this is such a
heartfelt appearance thank you for
having me drew and
until next time
[Music]